as far as right now being fifty
competing versus forty competing thirty
competing twenty-five competing what's
the biggest difference you're feeling
with your body I really don't feel
anything with my body to be honest with
you I don't have any aches or pains
anywhere
that newbie machine I use for my legs
has taken so much pressure off my knees
that I don't feel anything in my knees
so I'm able to go heavier than I
normally you know then I've normally
been going and and it still keeps the
pressure of my knees so that's why I've
been able to bring my legs back you know
what I'm saying so that was the main
thing and everything else my joints feel
good overall I feel amazing I can do
this another 10 15 years if I feel like
you can go another 10 years yeah of
course I can so if you can go another 10
years and why are you talking my
retirement because you know in your
heart when it's time to let it go it's
time it's 22 years it's just it's time
to let it go on top but you specifically
said I will retire when I stop competing
in the top six I did say that and I have
been saying that but but you want to
listen to your mind and your heart too
and my heart says it's time to let it go
it's time to go and go on to bigger and
better things and that's what it's time
to do interesting you know a lot of
people don't believe you're gonna be
done a lot of people think because and
the reason for this not you know how
some people you watch a play and you say
you know I think he should have retired
two years before well you know what
after what I presented this past weekend
a lot of people are saying that I even
thought of myself for a second I was
like hell no no yo ass is retired so I
am really done you guys gonna be
surprised I don't start crying when you
boy gone but I'm definitely gonna retire
this is my final year and I've always
said I'm gonna give myself you know like
you just said I I've always said as long
as I'm in the top five that's just me
talking as long as I'm in the top five
I'm you know I'm gonna continue
competing yeah or or as long as the body
holds up or whatever it may be
I've always said that but I've never and
I've always said I've give myself a year
but I've never said I'm retired this is
it this year I've never said that this
is the first time I've said it I want to
record saying it and it's gonna happen
how did that decision come about how'd
you make the meeting like - me and my
mom fiance we sit down and and my family
talked about it and we just feel it's
the right time any specific reason for
it or it just wasn't the words kind of
like so many other business opportunity
that's what I have to pursue right and I
can't do it why I'm still competing it's
just too much going on you know I'm away
from my family a lot of people don't
know that I'm away from my family
probably eight months out of the year I
go to LA State LA just to Train you know
I train with Charles glass out there
I've I had an apartment out there for
ten years now so it's rough on the
family too you know if it wasn't
FaceTime we probably does FaceTime saves
lives saves relationships
so definitely FaceTime is what helped me
and her be able to communicate and we
both got to understand them because she
was the main one to say well look Dex
you need to go out there you know cuz at
first when I started going out there I
started training with Charles glass okay
and I was go out there for two weeks
plug all my stuff back to the Florida
stayed there for another two weeks then
go back out to LA train with Charles for
two weeks and spending all this money on
you know vehicles to rent and and and
hotels and she said you know what you
need to just find a place out there
just stay out there and train keep all
your stuff out there that when you got
to worry about lugging it back you know
you have everything out there that you
need and then when the show is over just
come on back home and and have your
family time and I could come out there
and chill out there you know sometimes
there a few times there a year and which
is what we do and so we got a very good
understanding and it's amazing to have a
woman behind you once a person like that
that's gonna support you so guys if you
out there man you got a good woman like
that you need to hold on to that woman
because she is definitely the backbone
of
you know what I got going on my
relationship and all that stuff man
she's amazing girl is
[Music]